guess what the minimalists are going on
tour with a live version of the
minimalists podcast
and i want to invite you to join us for
a night of less find your nearest city
at the minimalists comm slash tour we'll
see you there
our question is from Marie how can I
have memories and memory boxes and still
be a clutter free minimalist I mean so
so we need to parse out these two things
right and unfortunately we conflate
memories with our memory boxes quite
literal yeah we have boxes and bins and
crates and and storage lockers and
containers and bread boxes and old
cookie jars and all of these things that
clutter every bit of our homes they
they're in the Attic they're in the the
guest bedroom storage closet they all of
these places that we just store these
things why because we say well I want to
keep my memories in there but how often
do we actually access those things yeah
we can access the memories without
accessing the things and so my pithy
answer for you is an oldie but a goodie
our memories are not in our things our
memories are inside us yeah I think once
we realize that that I can let go of
something and still retain the memory
that I have of the thing or of the
experience that I experience with the
thing it gives me permission to let go
now
what I will say is also sometimes our
things can trigger the memories inside
us so before I let go of some of my
things what I'll do is I'll take a I'll
snap a photo of it and having that photo
still gives me the trigger to the memory
without having to hold on to the the
giant you sideboard cabinet or whatever
I just realized like thinking about this
question we are we're scared of being
forgotten but like what's worse than
being forgotten is forgetting our own
lives and I think that is why we know
that's why I
I used to have the memory boxes it was I
wanted to remember every little detail
of my life that I could but yeah when I
went through those memory boxes like
during my packing party I realized that
hey maybe these aren't memories I want
to sit here and cling to ya and be they
really weren't that awesome of a memory
anyway and see you can create new and
should be creating memories see better
memories with the experiences we have
because Ryan you bring up a really great
point if we're always clinging to the
memories of the past we're not making
room for the memories we're creating
right now you know something pithy there
Sean
you